hello good morning everybody um welcome
to the talk on beijan network modeling
and uh using python anr um I am a
technical architect with CJ Federal and
I have a PhD in computation sciences and
informatics and there is the inspiration
for this
stock let's look at the agenda the
agenda involves looking at the
applications of beian network and uh
looking at how it was derived from Bas
law and the theories of bean Network
we'll follow that with an understanding
of the BN ecosystem in both Python and
R so let's first take a look at the
applications of beian network so the
very first application which I could
come up and it's a somber example is uh
uh in the early morning of June 1 2009
airron flight af447 went missing it went
missing with 228 passengers in Crews and
it disappeared over the Atlantic
Ocean tried multiple techniques and they
could not uh figure out the location of
the debris of the flight but later on
they decided they should look try to use
uh Bean Network modeling and as part of
that they realized it works uh it worked
successfully for them and this is the
model that was used for it um as you can
see there's a mention of posterior and
prior in this chart but um don't worry
about it right now we'll cover that
later we um but as you can see it's a it
involves multiple parameters on which
the r and posteriors has been taken so
they learned from whatever efforts did
not work and they um tried to use it to
the advantage in making the
prediction it has also been used
election season so you can imagine it's
been used in the um election prediction
the polls Nate Sila all of you may have
heard of him from 538 Blog and R Lindo
from itic they do use uh ban uh methods
for the prediction of course they do use
multiple other techniques but ban
network is uh one of the Prime ones and
uh it's been known to work some of the
other applications are your Office
Products uh Microsoft Office Products
office assist which use for asking
questions and learning more about the
product that uses be modeling and the
other applications are like uh
discovering the relations between genes
the environment and the disease
propagation for a given
population that's where beijan modeling
is being used as well as like for in the
astronomy field particularly solar
science where they're trying to predict
the
um solar flare predictions like as you
know the so sun is dynamic and it has
these solar flares which occur from time
to time being able to predict that so
from this you would get an idea that
there are varied fields and domains
where basian network is being used used
and can be used um so if you have a
problem going forward uh hopefully this
particular talk will give you an
introduction to beian network and when
you have a problem to solve you will
think and try to analyze if beian
modeling makes sense to use as part of
your particular problem or
not so let's look at some of the Python
and our packages which deal with beian
network modeling those are the names uh
we will look into a few of them as
examples after I've had a chance to
explain what visian network modeling is
all
about so what let's start from the
beginning of base law um if you I know
equations can get a little scary so just
hold on to this there are very few
equations in this presentation and this
is one of the few of thems um so as you
can see what we are trying to see here
is the base theorem or also which which
is often told as Bas law Bas rule so you
hear that they interchangeable they they
represent the same thing what it's
trying to give you more information on
is what is the probability of a given B
which is the very first part of the
equation P of a bar B that means what is
the probability of a occurring given B
has already occurred you have
information about B how do you leverage
that to have a better understanding of a
a could be anything for example in as I
mentioned I've used this in my PhD study
so what I used it for was determining
the distances of galaxies so for me a
was the distance of the Galaxy B was all
the attributes of the Galaxy that I have
that are already measured and I can use
it to be able to better predict the
distance of the Galaxy in your case for
your particular problem you'll have to
appropriately Define what a is and what
B is B usually means that that's all the
data and the measurements that you
already have and you want to leverage to
better understand a particular problem
that you're trying to
solve so it's as you can understand when
I'm saying that there is data available
and you're trying to leverage it to
solve some particular problem so what
essentially you're doing is based on
evidence based on the data that you have
which is your evidence you're trying to
come up with a degree of belief for the
possible outcomes possible outcomes are
the different ways the the problem
you're trying to solve can
occur so going back to my example it
could be that the outcomes are is the
distance of the Galaxy of um red shift
0.1 or is it Point 2 or 3 so those are
the possible outcomes and I'm getting as
after applying Vision networks I get an
understanding of what is the how much
can I believe from the data that I have
if the distance of the Galaxy is 0.1 or
if the distance is0 2 or3 so I get
specific numbers for
that and this is Thomas Bas who had come
up with the Bas law um it's very
interesting how he came up with the law
uh actually he was not credited for it
when he was alive it became more popular
ously so if you're interested in history
of mathematics uh it's I would
definitely encourage you to go check it
out and learn more about him and the way
the base law came about to
be so again going trying to put it in a
more graphical format what I've been
telling about data evidence and coming
up with the degree of belief for the
outcomes it's that your evidence which
also the term used for it is prior as
you remember in the first slide when I
was talking about the airron that there
were certain prior posterior so the
terms could become a little more clear
here so your evidence is your prior it
represents the belief or the
likelihood which is used for prediction
or coming up with a posterior
probability
which represents your potential
outcomes so hopefully this chart gives
you a little bit more clarity in case
you are not from probability and
statistics background but they should
give a better idea of what what is prior
what is likelihood and what is posterior
because the these three terms keep
coming up often when you're working with
beian
networks now specifying a prior
probability can be tricky why because it
is a subjective element if you have data
and you're very sure that data
measurements are all good then oh well
and good you can use that but quite
often it is a subjective element where
the person applying the algorithm has to
make a decision as
to these are the probabilities that I
want to go with for the data that I
already have or the elements that I'm
trying to use to come up with the
outcomes so that becomes subjective and
it can lead to lot of U confusion lot of
controversy over there because your
findings are as you can see your
posterior or your prediction is based on
your evidence or the prior so if your
prior is incorrect of course your
prediction will be incorrect we all know
that your prediction is as good as the
data that you have so when it comes to
beijan network modeling your prior
probability is important it's important
to get it as correct as possible but
that should not prevent you from getting
started with the exercise of applying
this this Pro problem of specifying the
prior probability is also known as the
reference class problem so if you want
to look that up you'll get some
interesting anecdotes and examples where
it has been an
issue so essentially what are we doing
with beian modeling is predicting future
based on past observations or the
priors and that what does that mean that
means that it lends itself naturally to
applications which require Predictive
Analytics Predictive Analytics is a term
which is really hot these days and uh we
keep talking of how can we better
improve uh on the data that we have and
so since beian networks does that
whenever you're working with Predictive
Analytics application I'll definitely
encourage you
to consider beian Network modeling as
one of the approaches that you can use
for your particular
problem and the best part of beian
network is your belief is being updated
or can be updated as more evidence
becomes available which is a well-known
problem with some of the Predictive
Analytics model where as more data
becomes available your it becomes
difficult to update the model whereas in
this case the information associated
with the model can be updated as more
evidence becomes available and that
makes it a uh an technique which is uh
which is more convenient and uh more
usable for any given
problem
this is
um you're all familiar with this whole
um what do you say the uh argument of R
versus python so this is a similar
argument which goes on with between in
the statistics field is frequentist
versus beijan there are people who are
really passionate for one or the other
and you can have arguments all lifelong
for all you care because they they're
really passionate about stuff um I'm not
one of them and I'll uh I'll not be able
to argue with you for one or the other
but I have used Bean Network and I found
it useful so here I am how does Bean
contrast with frequentist is that in
frequentist the observations are modeled
as a physical system whose measurements
are not exact so that's the reason
you'll have to account for error and you
come up with models for from the data
that you
have those are typically the
distributions you assume like is it an
normal distribution is it a gamma
distribution is it a beta distribution
and you do those type of analysis and
from the data you try to come up with
the estimates for the parameters for
those models Bion is kind of different
and we'll be going into more detail in
the following slides so in the
frequentist concept the probability of
an event is the relative frequency over
time that is proportion of outcome I
have run this thing 100 times and it has
occurred 20 times so the probability is
20 by 100 in beijan world there's a
different concept for that which is
called likelihood and that uh or the
belief um I should go back so in the
beian side it is referred to as belief
and they don't use the term probability
the belief says that I am sure that
it'll occur 20 of 100 times because I've
have seen it occur 20 of 100 times so
that's one of the main the main way in
which your thought has to be different
when you're working with Bean versus
when you're working with the frequentist
sorry can you repeat that one more
time yeah in frequentist they say that
they'll use the term probability whereas
in the basian side they'll use the term
belief so if an event occurs 20 of 20
times of the 100 times you have run and
run through it in frequen side they'll
say it's 2 times my probability is
point2 here they'll say the belief is
that it will occur two so you can see
the slight difference way um or rather
there's a big difference in the way you
are looking at both those numbers in in
one you are you still thinking about it
you have a probability or uncertainty
around it whereas in uh basian side
they're saying there's a belief for it
and there's an uncertainty for
it so the first equation must we looking
familiar it's the base law so we're
trying to understand again what is the
posterior prior from that
excuse
me so over there you can see um if we re
rewrite the equation a little bit
differently it comes out in the second
format over here not the uh White uh
white image over there but the one right
below it so as you can see and then
that's termed as probability of a given
B that is you you're trying to formulate
your problem saying that I want to
figure out what is the probility of
something occurring given that I have
this information that's called posterior
and the other block is there and the
prior and this particular piece is
called support of B for
a so if we replace um A and B with O and
H I think that becomes a little bit more
clear um where H stands for the
hypothesis or you're saying that my um
the red shift of the Galaxy is 0.1 what
is the belief associated with it and my
observations is the the data set that I
have so just reformulating that whole
equation by replacing a with um H and B
with o you get that equation since we
have the data at hand the probability of
that data occurring is
one that's the reason you can remove it
from that whole equation and it comes
down to this particular line over here
which means that your posterior is equal
to likelihood into
prior okay I think this was one of the
last slides with equations Let's uh move
on and get into more on how we actually
run beian network analysis in R and
python this is the example um this is
the the x-axis corresponds to predicted
value and the y axis says what's the
confidence of the predicted value so I
ran aan Network modeling on my problem
and this is the information that I got
as you can see the probab sorry I I
should use the term belief or confidence
instead of probability
um so for the different predicted values
what is the confidence associated with
them and I have charted that so you you
could what you would want to as a very
simplistic application is go for the one
with the maximum probability because you
think that that's most likely to
occur and that's often called the most
probable osteri or map value but you
could use this information in multiple
ways you could average out the highest
values or you could take a subset of
values and say these are the four five
values which are most likely to occur so
that's up to you and you can um that
increases the complexity of your
analysis and
solution and so that was base law now
let's move on to beian belief Network
this is based on the base law where we
saw that there was a relationship
between observation and the hypothesis
in the basian belief Network gives a
whole graphical look and feel to to the
whole problem and your
solution it was pioneered by G PE um
2011 ACM teing Award winner so what
these graphical models of the
information that you have or the model
that has been generated by your ban
Network represents it each of the node
represents a variable in your data set
and the no and the arcs or the
connections they represent if there's a
relationship between those two
attributes or not so for example in this
particular one star is my U whatever is
my target or whatever I'm trying to
estimate so I'm seeing that that is
dependent only on the gr attribute or
the column in my data set I can safely
based on my beian modeling I can safely
ignore these three attributes now you
would think
that this becomes very simple for the
Target that I'm having but the but the
level of information that is included in
this chart that is
something very interesting in the sense
that we are not just modeling the target
but we also have a model for the
remaining attributes and an
understanding of how the other
attributes depend on other attributes
what is the relationship among them for
example even though this model I'll use
to predict my star but if I have missing
attributes in I like there are sorry
missing values there are certain records
which don't have any values in I I can
use use this model to estimate those
missing values so I have a model which
represents the entire data set that I
have or the relationships of the
different attributes in that data set
and which can be used to better
understand the relationships and the
interconnections between the different
attributes Nave base is another term you
may have commonly used it's a special
case of the beian network where we
assume that
that the the element that you're trying
to predict that is the parent node and
all the other it depends on all the
other features that are there in your
data set but there is no
interrelationship between the other
attributes so as you can see this is a
this is the most simple form of a basion
network in basan networks these
attributes in turn can have
relationships and there are different
algorithms which will do that for you
and that increases the complexity and
the kind of problems the bean Network
can
handle you may be thinking how does this
work with numeric data how would it um
formulate the relationships in that what
you would do is you would come
discretize your data come up with
categories for your numeric attributes
uh one simple way is like give ranges
saying that if my number is from 1 to 10
that's one category it's from 10 to 20
is another category and the most
simplest way or you could use quantiles
which will split your data into equal
buckets and that you could use them as
your
categories and this uh the number of
data brakes that you use or the number
of splits that you use of your numeric
data that's very important for how uh
complex your problem is how much it can
address and while you're trying to avoid
and overfit that you're not your model
is not entirely capturing the um
intricacies of the data it's generic
enough what are the different ways you
could evaluate your models are you look
at the characterist of the Network like
as I was showing you the earlier chart
where there was this uh interconnection
between different attributes you can
better understand your network um of and
the relationship between the attributes
combination of multiple generated
networks run visan network multiple
times on your data come up with multiple
networks look at them which are most
often which links are most often
occurring include them uh actually the r
example that uh I'll be showing that
does that so you'll get a better idea of
what I mean by combination of multiple
generated networks as we already talked
uh it's an intelligent Aid in fixing
your missing data you can use your model
for that purpose and of course you want
your model to be to have high predictive
accuracy while also being good in terms
of the execution
time so these are the different possible
types of ban networks um when you're
looking at algorithms to implement when
you want if you want to solve your
problem using Bean networks these are
the potential different ways I'll not go
into too much detail on them but as you
remember I said uh Nave Bas is a special
case of ban network but there are these
other ones um if I may I I I can excuse
me the one or k dependence ban networks
it's it's a tree format of your network
and it's saying that every attribute can
only depend on one other attribute if it
is a one dependence network if if you're
coming off with a K dependence where K
is greater than one so you say you have
a three dependence Network you are
saying that that you telling your
algorithm that I want to formulate a
network where there can be maximum three
interconnections or three other
attributes on which a given attribute
Can
Depend Qui question so I so n is the
most commonly used right is the most
robust technique like what what what's
the main driver it's one of the simplest
because as you can see it doesn't
involve the complexity of
interconnections and trying to figure
that out you are taking whatever you
want to predict that is the parent road
so you can see it's much more simpler to
specify than having to run through the
algorithm figure out if your models uh
how you models are converging and uh if
you see two different networks they'll
have different interconnection showing
up due to that Nave base is uh more more
commonly
used good question thank
you so for the beian network again the
algorithm categories they fall into
these two main things constraint based
and scoring based um I have the
definitions there where constraint based
says that U you're trying to find the
conditional Independence among the
attributes and you're using that
information to come up with your tree
structure or U your attribute
relationship structure it's more
efficient than the score based approach
um particularly when you have large
number of uh data set large your data
set is large at that point you would
want to look at the constraint based
scoring based is where um it
heuristically formulates a network of
the different attributes you have in
your data set and then you also have a
scoring method so from the network
formulated you score it and you say that
is it meeting my threshold or not if
it's meeting your threshold you accept
it as one of the models or you don't so
as you can see there's are two different
ways of trying to come up with that
network of attributes in your data
set and of course there can be hybrids
of both those method
methods um so we we have hopefully this
has given you a little bit more clarity
on beian networks prior likelihood and
posterior and what beian networks
actually mean let's go ahead and take a
look at the what's the bean Network
equos system in Python and
R so this slide should look familiar we
have seen it earlier it's the set of
packages which are available in Python
and R and the three dots at the end of
the list should tell you that there's
lots more of course this list is not
exhaustive as you you you may have
guessed earlier on itself
um so of course um py learn numai and
Matt Matt sorry Matt plot live is the
first example we are looking at um most
of you I'm guessing of if you've been
working with python for a long time you
are familiar with this particular
package which is a set of scientific
algorithms so SK scipi stands for
Scientific Python so there's a lot of
algorithms that have been implemented
the one we are taking a look at here is
how do you uh formulate a model and
formulate a basian model and how do you
predict on it so you you are um how do
you install it is in the very first line
over there uh cond install sky kit learn
if you have if you're using anaconda and
then uh there's the package called SK
learncore native um sorry SK learn.
native uncore Bas from which you can
import the gajian and B um stands for
nabas so this is a nabas example from
sky sky kit that I'm showing here you
get your data populated you import the
library you get your data populated then
you are creating a gan classifier you're
training the model and then you use it
to predict so this is the typical flow
you would go through irrespective of
whichever package you are using for your
analysis sorry can you talk a little bit
about the requirements of the data set
and the sort of testing they you have to
do regarding like normality and
colinearity between
uh usually just like run the model you
usually run the model if there's some
type of normalization you want to do
you're more than welcome to do it but
definitely you can take the data put it
into your model identify which is your
target variable and then U uh let the
model run on it the has no requirement
for it being normal uh if you're trying
to just run it through your data then
yes but uh you can do the necessary
analysis beforehand that's beyond the
scope of this talk we can keep on
talking about
that but if you have a data set and you
just want to see how it performs with
then yes this is your approach but yeah
there's lot more you can do in advance
to make sure that the uh approaches you
are using are applicable or not but that
should not prevent you from trying it
out good
question okay and there's um few other
examples I have here um you could use
your um again Sky kit learn um gajan
mixture beigan gajian mixture I'll just
skip through this I'll have a GitHub um
URL available for my talk if you can
reach out to me later on I can make it
available or also include it in the
slide the copy that is made available
later on um so all this code should be
available for you to try it out on your
own later on do you have any sample of
the exploratory analysis that proceeds
modeling if you're going to actually
like extract findings from it for that
that you've done do you have any samples
on your GitHub um I don't have it on
GitHub but I can make it available uh I
have from my um other exercise data
related stuff that I have done
definitely let's catch up after the talk
if you have any specifics that you want
okay this is the second package um that
we I want to quickly go through is the
base pie uh this um so one thing I've
realized when you're looking at these
packages is that uh each there are
multiple packages available but they
don't Implement everything which which
is kind of understanding handable right
but each of these packages have certain
Niche areas that they address one good
example of that is BAS P it only covers
the variational ban inference um for a
particular type of U distribution
data actually somebody just mentioned
this morning that there's a talk which
is entirely dedicated to variational ban
analysis this this afternoon so if
you're really interested please do check
it out and it may be a good
um next presentation after this
particular talk so and this has only
been implemented for Python 3 so if
you're working with python 2 this will
not work this Library cannot be used so
take a look at that and they have
certain good examples these are the
examples on their website so do take a
look at these as potential
users the third library that I um had a
quick look at was Bas Lo block um it's a
C++ and python
implementation um the the links are I've
provided links on uh the examples using
this particular package the best part of
this is that they have certain building
blocks so even if you are not well
acquainted with what Bean network
analysis involves you can look at these
blocks and put them together and get it
working as a python ban Network
application
so I thought that was really neat that
they um they have used the blocks
concept and which can make it much more
easier to use a particular Library
compared to having to um go through each
and every integrative detail steps of
implementing a particular
Library so the blocks include steps the
blocks are like defining Gan variables
performing summation multiplication and
those type of different operations you
would perform on your data as part of
your bean network
analysis and this is a code example from
that so you could kind of see that
there's a pattern where you're trying to
get the data you learn the model and
then you're performing inference on it
and the syntax or the particular method
name that you're using to perform these
different steps are different across the
different libraries and you put them all
together to be able to do your um
prediction so let's quickly take a look
at R um so those were the few python
libraries that I had a chance to look at
there are lots more there are lots more
which are like windbergs Stan and uh
Jags these three I I see a lot of
Articles coming up where they're using
these three libraries so you may want to
check check them out
um so moving on to R uh R has this page
uh which is a crown task view of forban
so this lists almost all the different
packages that are available in R um
relevant to Bean Network
modeling the the list that is shown on
the top of the the the image here are
the the ones which are applicable for
General data cases for your General
application the list below are for
specific models so as I've mentioned
like there are lots of packages
available but some
are some are something you can take and
start using for your data but there are
some which are very specific for a
particular type of data for a particular
use case and they have very Niche very
specific cases that they can handle so
though this list of General model is
eight there are about 80 or 80 plus
packages which can handle your specific
case so if the problem you are trying to
address is in that Niche case uh you
should definitely check out the special
packages um but if you don't know what
exact category your problem is or what
is the specific case uh that your
problem specific data distribution Etc
then definitely start with the general
packages and then move on to your
specific cases as you get more
understanding of your data and the need
of your app
application so my favorite our package
is BN learn it's Bean Network learn they
have implemented multiple of algorithms
um if you remember I had mentioned there
are two categories constraint based and
the score based types of ban algorithms
so B and learn has implemented most of
them you can run um you can develop your
code and run through each of them
multiple times and see which one
performs better on your data because
again the performance of the algorithm
depends on the characteristics of your
data so you would want to run through
those different algorithms figure out
which one is uh the most um which has
high predictive accuracy as well as
which is executing in much lesser
time so if you take a look at this
particular one you see that we splitting
the data into training and test U that's
this method that I particular I use for
my own uh split train and test then
you're building a uh 200 node
uh
networks sorry you're Building 200
networks using hill climbing which is
one of the score-based algorithms there
are other score based algorithms which
are there as part of this package but I
am as part of this example I'm using
hill climbing so I am using the
algorithm Etc I'm generating 200
networks from my data and then in the
next step I'm saying that of these 200
networks I have
generated create a network which
includes the nodes that have occurred in
85% of those 200 networks so I formulate
200 networks from those for the
interconnections that are there between
the attributes I only retain the ones
which occurred in 85% of those networks
the rest I drop so that gives me a more
strong Network which has consistently
occurred in 85% of my 200
networks then I have the network then I
use the datas that I have to formulate
the joint probability distribution for
the different relationships that are
showing up in the
interconnections and um this one is just
a uh graph V package which you can use
to
um which you can use to for um review
the Network that has been
generated and this is the inference
phase where you have generated the model
now you want to run it on your test data
and uh uh and predict using the model
predict for the test data how the model
is performing so again this should all
be available in the
GitHub and you try to come up with the
excuse me if you remember the earlier
there was a plot where I was showing the
uh predicted values and the confidence
associated with it so this particular
way I'm trying to find which one has the
maximum probability and I want to use
that
there's another package called beian
Network so that gives you a more
graphical user interface to use for
working with the BN learn package if
you're trying to start learning BN learn
package go ahead and use this this is a
very new package and it has a lot of NE
functionalities and helps to learn it
faster and um in a more fun way than
having to run commands and the other
application is um Stan which I mentioned
is one of the other applications so it
is available for both Python and R so if
you want to come up with something that
is applicable in both Python and R
definitely give this a
shot so sharing some of my experiences
is that um before you start thinking
that you can use a particular package
spend some time reviewing the
documentation to understand what type of
functionalities it supports and uh and
if it's actually will be applicable to
your problem or not um so use that
important to be aware of the packages
support for for python 2 versus Python 3
that may be your first decision point if
you are if you cannot change your python
version from one or the other then that
becomes a good um attribute to use to
make your decision um one thing which
I've heard most of my data scientist
friends uh often um say is how they work
is quickly experiment in R Implement in
Python um but of course that's not
universally applicable it will be
depending on your use case um but
definitely something you can consider
and when you're working with r try to
come up with r shiny applications uh
just the way the earlier screenshot
where it was um showing a guy for
learning B and learn that's definitely
much more easier because you don't have
to keep on changing your parameters and
the command line and running it your GUI
gives you a better way to be able to
experiment all the different
functionalities that are available as
part of your particular package that
you're experimenting and particularly if
you're trying to tune the parameters Etc
look for existing code examples and all
of us are aware of that um GitHub cran
um Google stack
Overflow there some of the ways which
most of us use and of course keep
experimenting that's the best way to
learn
um so thank you for your time and I'm
open for
[Applause]
questions
can you uh compare this with uh I'm not
sure about the difference between B
networks and probabilistic
programming and also should we think of
this as an optimization or should we
think of it as you're trying
to put in uh like a your data generation
process so which next question you think
about sh the question was uh can I give
a little bit more clarity into the
difference between beian modeling and
the probabilistic modeling and uh the
other question was U if this is a data
generation or a optimization problem so
the first one I think I covered earlier
on in the talk that uh there are two
thought processes of the statisticians
one is the probabilistic way of thinking
and the other one is the basian network
modeling or basian uh thought process in
uh probabilistic model they depend on
how frequently something is occurring
and they leverage that
information no no my question
is there's this phrase called probab
program so is this a form of
probabilistic programming I'm not
familiar with the term probabilistic
programming so I will not take a guess
on that if you want to give a little bit
more detail on what do you mean by
probabilistic problem are you referring
to using different uh libraries to get a
better understanding of the
data so this could be considered as a
type of probabilistic programming where
you are you have your data using that
you try to better understand the um the
data the relationships between the
attributes and uh use that to further
enhance your data as well as to be able
to predict on certain things and the
other thing was is it a data generation
or optimization problem this is a data
modeling approach this is uh you are
optimizing on it as well you're trying
to come up with a model around your data
um so how you would do any type of
Predictive Analytics is Al you could use
U Bean modeling as one of the approaches
it's one of the modeling techniques so
like decision trees um so ban modeling
is a type of a decision tree as well but
it it includes much more I have to think
about the distributions on every note
that I right it's not just have you you
get that interconnection and then based
on your data you come up with the joint
probability distribution your data is
letting you come up with the joint
probability distribution for a given
node
yes please how are you measuring the
interactions between the
attributes that's in the whole the
algorithm which generates the network
where you could use uh constraint based
or you could use uh score based methods
if you remember this
[Applause]
slide so that's how the network is
formulated so there are two different
approaches where see this this you will
you will never be able ble to come up
with an exact solution for the data you
have it's an NP hard problem so you'll
have to come up with approximate and
heuristics uh based approaches and these
two are the two two different ways of
coming up with those approximate or htic
Solutions one is where you um take two
attributes at a time and you you you
have the data with you so try to
understand what is the conditional um
Independence among them if they
conditionally independent there's no
interconnection between them so you
using something like correlation or or
not you could use U there are multiple
ways in which you could uh you could
Define your
correlation
measurement any other questions yes
please you mentioned you use this in
your PhD research um how large is that
data set and you know of any
applications of this for very large data
that can't F on a single mod yes um
there were a lot of applications which I
mentioned they are big data problems my
data set was about 1 million records um
but it the best part of visan networks
is is that you could uh run it on
multiple nodes like for my case I ran
the same algorithm I I got the model
then I ran it in multiple nodes so I get
the prediction from the multiple
nodes you said your information avilable
the
last um information as in the GitHub URL
or what's your GitHub hand GitHub handle
is my first name but you
can
my GitHub handle is my first name
only I mean I was just
hoping